i'd like to think that the dumbest one
that was pitched
is in the game i can't imagine us going
well that's really dumb that doesn't
belong in a friendship mode
dumb funny things is what all friendship
moves are about
hi my name is ed boon i am the creative
director at netherrealm
studios we are about to go through every
single
friendship move in mortal kombat 11.
[Music]
a friendship move is a friendly version
of a fatality
after the reactions to some of our
fatalities from the early mortal kombat
games
we decided to create the anti-fatality
friendship a friendship is a childish
funny
novel finishing move that the players
can do
when they don't want to really do
something too violent and we're going to
cover
all 37 characters including our three
new fighters
rain molina and rambo who joined the
roster as part of mortal kombat 11
ultimate
and combat pack 2.
[Music]
baraka's friendship move is actually
based on
his friendship move from mortal kombat
2. way back in the 90s we had
much less sophisticated presentation
baraka used to just take out a present
and present it to
his opponent now in 2020
we can do much more of an elaborate
performance now he takes out the cake he
throws it up in the air
he cuts it up there's just this big mess
so we're just kind of playing
on that original idea but updating it
with a much more
elaborate presentation
[Music]
cassie's friendship move is kind of like
our social commentary on
what younger people are doing these days
and so it's all about the selfie it's
all about
social media and creating a persona
[Music]
it's funny that she went through this
crazy brutal fight and then
as a celebration she takes out her cell
phone and begins to kind of document
what she looked like after the fight i
always found that friendship move
one of the more humorous ones in the
game
i think every single friendship move
that we do
it'll be one out of four or five ideas
that are being pitched and then based on
the complexity of it how funny we think
it is
how dumb we think it is if we think a
friendship move is dumb that's usually a
really good sign
the whole point of these things is to be
silly to be the opposite of a fatality
to
get laughter out of somebody rather than
shock because we have
almost 40 friendship moves in the game a
lot of the ones that we did not use
i've somehow forgotten all about cedrion
if you're familiar with cetriana she's
all about balance and she's all about
good and evil so her friendship move is
also all about balance
she brings up a tree it's all about
nature and everything and then
generates a swing and is just swinging
and enjoying the balance of nature
it's not an elaborate friendship but it
certainly reflects
her personality dvora's friendship
she has always had ties with the insect
world
it actually starts out a little bit
dramatic she turns into a cocoon and
then the exact
opposite of what you're expecting
happens she basically bursts
out as a butterfly
[Applause]
the irony of she's always been the most
disgusting
representation of bugs and then kind of
coming out at the other end of the
spectrum with this butterfly
is quite fitting for her if we were to
give her a friendship move
aaron black aaron black is a
gunslinger we figured what is the most
non-threatening
use of guns that we can think of
i love the way this friendship move
starts
really dramatic you kind of see his head
tilting up almost like a clint eastwood
movie and then we quickly transition to
the carnival shooting gallery
you see glimpses of this idea used for
other friendships we're gonna see
something similar to that in the future
but
this whole how quickly he does a quick
shot
is probably one of my favorite kind of
like setting that's created
in in this friendship with aaron black
[Music]
frost like sub-zero having this kind of
cold power you knew it was going to have
something to do with ice
we decided to make an ice skating rink
one of my favorite things about this
particular
friendship is the animations we don't
have an ice skating rink in our motion
capture studio but somehow
our animation team and mocap team
duplicated the feeling
of ice skating and so she's skating
around the arena
her spinning move at the very end is is
particularly funny just because her head
stays still while her body kind of
rotates it i still don't know how those
guys pull that one off
much of what gives the realism in terms
of the feel and look with our games is
the fact that we
grab a lot of our animations through
motion capture so we have motion capture
talent come in we actually have them
perform the moves
for frost what was so particularly
exciting is the fact that we did not
have a skating rink so we could not
capture it live but
our animators can really perform
miracles as far as
getting the perfect look and feel so it
was a combination of
motion capture but a lot of animation
magic put on top of that
[Music]
fujin is the god of wind
naturally we wanted to have his
friendship move be of him flying a kite
he experiences all the struggles that a
kid does trying to get the kite in the
air
he decides to use his powers to make the
kite get off the ground what's so funny
about this friendship for
me is that he's actually skipping he's
skipping like a child which is
so kind of in the spirit of what
friendship moves are
in retrospect i wish that we had raiden
come out who's fujin's brother
flying the kite together i think it
would have been just that extra kind of
oomph for it
but we could not be happier with how
this friendship move turned out it's
easily one of the most playful in the
entire game
[Music]
garrus is one of the more almost random
and confusing
friendship moves we really were kind of
thinking what do you do with somebody
who has control over the sands of time
and of course you take those sands and
build a sand castle
one of the funny details i love about it
is the concentration that garrus has as
he's putting
that last flag on the top of the castle
he's got his tongue sticking out like he
just wants to put it in the exact right
place
my favorite part is his arms folding at
the end
looking at his masterpiece and he's so
happy and proud of it
that facial expression really sells the
whole thing for me
every single thing that we can do now is
something i wish we had
back in the day the technical struggles
way back
in the 90s were as big of a challenge as
coming up with the original ideas you
came up with the ideas and that was
great but then how do you do it when
you're kind of inside this box
now the box is gigantic it's a much
different challenge
but the capabilities are almost
limitless at this point
[Music]
jade's friendship is based on her staff
and when we were thinking what what do
kids do with something like a staff
the idea came up of a pinata so
jade swinging her staff at a pinata and
hundreds of pieces of candy flying out
is a very
fun friendship move for the team to make
what i love is the nuance of her
clapping
she's so happy with herself sitting down
with her legs crossed
and being almost kind of overwhelmed at
how much candy is in front of her
excitement almost taking over her as she
doesn't even know which piece of candy
to take so she's kind of frantically
grabbing every piece of candy that she
can even spot
that last moments there where she's just
in bliss
is really what sells this friendship
move most of the time we
look at the character in terms of their
abilities or something about their
costume that really stands
out based on those ideas what is
reasonable for us to create
we will pick the right one but normally
there is a
thread of a connection between the
character
and the friendship moves sometimes it's
a lot more of a
obvious connection and sometimes it's a
bit of a stretch but
those ones that are a bit of a stretch
are actually sometimes
the funnest ones jackie brings
jackie's friendship is the character
wanted to do something
something screwed up and that's the kind
of visual gag
jackie takes out like a punching bag and
she's using these kind of high-tech arms
you know kind of showing them off
punching this kind of rocking punching
bag she thinks that she gave it the
final blow and then it surprises
jackie and the audience and hits her
obviously because it's a friendship she
doesn't get
upset about it but it's certainly a bit
of a surprise and that's the kind of
visual gag so
hers is kind of like the first something
went wrong scenario that we have in the
game
jax jax's friendship move you can
almost called jax plays the sax
he is one of the simplest but stylized
friendship moves in the game
the music and the camera are some of the
biggest
parts of what gives this friendship move
the style he's got the subtle kind of
dancing going
the 70 shots with the multiple versions
of jax i love the background graphics
some people don't notice that when he
ends it he's actually playing the mortal
kombat theme
i love those kind of nuances that we put
in there johnny cage
johnny cage's friendship obviously has
to be related to showbiz
we wanted to add something unexpected so
he snaps his fingers
the lights go out and suddenly we're on
a stage
and he does this little dance number
with a
hat and cane the dancing is purposefully
hokey
that's part of the charm of it is he's
not a professional dancer but
he's so arrogant that he thinks he can
pull any of that stuff off
the little leg trick that he does at the
very end is funny and
when he ends it his hands are kind of
doing like a jazz hands thing
if you watch that friendship move a
number of times you'll pick up on little
nuances just like that
[Music]
john rambo's friendship is laser tag
i love the way it starts it has a clear
reference to the rambo movies where he's
suiting up
you think that something serious is
going on but when he clicks that gun
and you see it light up you know
something's different and boom we switch
to this
laser tag situation where he's in front
of and hiding behind the two
inflatable cover walls we go through a
sequence of his head
popping up taking shots at opponents
crawling between the two
shooting in a variety of ways it's a
classic
it's not what you think it is kind of
scenario
it'll be right between the eyes john
rambo helps finish out
our goal of getting as many 80s action
stars
in mortal kombat we've had terminator
we've had
robocop you are under arrest dirtbag and
now john rambo so
he really bookends that whole guest
character
roster that we have going machines are
either a benefit
or a hazard the thing about the licensed
characters that
was such a pleasant surprise for us was
that
we make the characters do such silly
things we were really concerned that the
the owners of the license would have an
issue with us doing something
as silly as he had but with rambo with
robocop with terminator
they were such great sports about it
that was one of the most pleasant
surprises in all of this was how
enthusiastic they were with having their
characters play along in this
silly portion of the game which is the
friendships
[Music]
joker has been in a number of nrs games
over the years
in mortal kombat 11 it's probably the
darkest representation that we've had
it was fun to see him back again in a
lighter
tone like jackie his friendship move is
another
something went wrong it starts off he's
trying to do something really sinister
with a gun
from out of the blue the batarang comes
out and hits him in the back of the head
he actually even references batman come
on
and then he switches over to
taking out some balloons at the end of
the day he says i'm sorry so
it's kind of like the batarang kind of
snapped him back into place into the
more
kinder gentler joker we really wanted to
have it be like a hint of batman come on
we certainly didn't want to have him
just come out and everybody's going to
be wanting to play him
if we actually created his model for the
game we've used joker three times before
mortal kombat versus dc
injustice 1 and injustice 2. in the t
rated games
we didn't want to kind of go crazy with
him in terms of
his his violent side and in mortal
kombat 11 that's when everything kind of
went loose
throwing joker into the mix with the
mortal kombat game
that's when you really get the
opportunity to take off all the reigns
and have him do crazy sick stuff
[Music]
cabal's friendship is probably one of
the most random friendships in the game
he zips onto the screen and there's this
gigantic xylophone that he starts
playing
probably what i'm most impressed with
this friendship
is the animation it is perfectly synced
to the music that is playing
you would never think that those were
two separate efforts that were done
by different team members again another
subtle reference to the mortal kombat
song i don't know how they managed to
time that so perfectly that's
a tribute to our animation and audio
team working together
as random as it was it's definitely one
of the more entertaining
friendship moves
kano was one of our more direct
friendship moves everybody thinks of
volcano
australian shrimp on the barbie so in
some respects we had to do
what we did kano uses his eye laser to
start a barbecue and he's got bratwurst
or something on there
if you look closely you will notice that
there are
shrimp on that barbecue i wish we had
him pick up a shrimp it would have been
a more direct reference but
for the people who are looking for those
details yes
i can confirm that there are shrimp on
that barbie
katana's friendship move is probably the
most friendliest
and perhaps innocent or childlike
since mortal kombat 11 was released
everybody has been clamoring for molina
i used to kind of troll people by saying
you know technically molina
is in the game because she's in katana's
friendship move where they play patty
cake they're traditionally very bitter
rivals
but the irony of seeing them play
together like sisters who grew up
together
is what is so cute about this friendship
move i love
at the very end there's like this nuance
where they actually mess up
and then they both realize it and they
both laugh that's what kind of like
bonds them together so they kind of give
each other a big hug
realizing that they messed up they're
just celebrating their their sisterhood
[Music]
collectors friendship is called a
one-man band friendship
[Music]
he pulls out a number of instruments
there's
drums there's a horn there's a flute
there's a guitar and he's playing them
all
the same time a one-man band you really
got to look at that one a number of
times to see the nuances that we
put in that friendship move again
everything is synced up from the cymbal
hits
to the horns all perfectly synced with
the music
the fact that he had four arms i guess
in reality we could have done that with
shiva or goro or motaro or
any one of the forearm characters but
the collector was the one
who we thought it matched a little bit
he's probably a little bit more
sophisticated than the monster type
characters
i'm sure that whoever animated it it was
a huge challenge to me it's like
like a hyper version of walking chewing
gum rubbing your stomach at the same
time
the fact that it has to be in tune with
the music and the individual four or
five instruments that he's playing at
the same time
i can't imagine being the one who has to
kind of coordinate
all of those things together
[Music]
kodokan's friendship is perhaps the
shortest and the simplest
like fujin he is a character who has
command of certain elements fujian with
wind
cortal is with the sun obviously we
thought okay let's have him pull out a
lawn chair and
get a suntan he pulls out a lawn chair
sits down gets one of those reflective
mirrors
to to make the most out of his
sunbathing
and it just chills one of the nuances
you notice if
you stare at his face he eventually
closes his eyes i don't know if he's
trying to fall asleep or if he's trying
to make sure
that his eyelids could also get suntan
the team
put a light source because we really
wanted his face to be lit up to put
something above him and then have it
reflect down
probably doesn't give us the kind of
precision control that we want but if
you set a light point where
the player can't see it you can really
frame codel's face with a lot more
precision and detail
[Music]
kung lao's friendship is another one of
the super childish
little nuances that kids do it starts
with his classic
teleport and then when he pops up a
train set appears
around his hat which is just perfect for
kung lao
and he is playing with the front engine
of the train and then he's spinning it
around
the nuances that i love of this
friendship move is
he's kicking his feet like little kids
do when they're watching tv or something
like that
those little touches that the animation
team the
cinema team puts in there just gives it
that
little extra oomph of childlike play
that makes these friendship moves feel
that much more
silly but in some ways endearing the old
friendship
where he throws his hat and the dog goes
to fetch it and if you keep in mind that
is his hat is made of razors at the edge
and you hear a yipe
a lot of people got that joke i think we
didn't want to repeat
that one just because things look so
much more real
today i don't want to see like a dog
that looks like a real dog end up with
that kind of demise
liu kang's friendship is it's the return
of the disco ball
like baraka it's a remake of an
old school friendship move that he had
where a disco ball would come down and
he would kind of do this dance
back in the day we had very little
memory to do it so he would just kind of
repeat the same
animation over and over again
this time it's a whole setup
you see the lights on the ground you see
the movements he has
choreography there's little hints of
like a saturday night fever point that
he does
the nuance again of this one i love is
he's a little bit
awkward he's not a professional dancer
there's a certain awkwardness which i
think is great it's a little
endearing dorkiness that he has where
he's doing the dance
but at the end of the day it's lou kang
he's got a lot of nobility
he hasn't really had much time to learn
about dancing and it kind of shows
molina's friendship we can call the
teddy bear tea party
if you notice the three teddy bears are
a teddy bear of molina
katana and jade and they're kind of like
our
famous female ninjas in a sense whenever
one of those characters is not in the
game everybody is clamoring for whatever
happened to this character we've gone
through that number of times
i love the way that when molina sets up
this tea party
she is constantly in the process of
making things even better she's
adjusting the teddy bears
she's pouring the tea her teddy bear
falls over she picks it up she's
applauding
she could not be happier to be there
that tea party
is just the perfect kind of summary of
the child-like
part of molina at the end of the day i
kind of wish we had done one of those
for the male ninjas it would have been
cool to see
scorpion sub-zero and rain or something
do the same thing
but we were able to do it with the
females and so that worked out great
[Music]
nightwell's friendship is pretty much an
animal act almost like a circus act
at first he pulls out this ring lights
on fire and you're just wondering is
this something more serious you see his
spirit
wolf come out what i love is the nuance
of him
tapping his leg enticing the the wolf to
jump through the hoop when it does
then everything cuts loose where the
eagles flying in
we see the bear in the background
balancing on the ball
and it's just this big staged circus act
what i found so entertaining about it is
nightwolf how intuitive he is you know
he's just coaxing the wolf to jump
through the hoop
and how proud he is holding the eagle at
the very end
like i taught these animals how to do
this it's such a funny situation to be
set up
this might actually be my favorite
friendship move
in the game easily it's in the top three
for me it starts
out with him splitting into three as a
clone and then
a jump rope sequence
this was a fun idea i think it worked
out great but
it was absolutely sold by the
performance
one of our motion capture talent his
name is nate he just went
crazy with it so you see all the nuances
i've never seen somebody in a motion
capture studio have
so much fun contributing to the spirit
of one of our cinematic moments the ink
splashes on the ground as his
hands and his feet make contact with it
is such a great detail of it but again
it's that performance and the animation
i've never seen something
communicate joy so much as to that guy
dancing and jumping rope at the same
time it was just such a such a great
performance
raiden's friendship along with liu kang
and baraka
and a number of other characters is a
nod to
their original friendship move raiden's
was called
kid thunder
and kid thunder makes a return in mortal
kombat 11.
a much more elaborate choreographed
light dance return so raiden summons can
thunder
and we hear that kind of familiar kid
thunder yell
we see this great light dance
performance the detail of him doing that
kind of
break dance moment and you'll notice if
you wait until the very end
he kind of gives this look to his dad
almost like he's looking for approval or
something like that you have to see
those
friendship moves a number of times to
pick all of those up
reigns friendship is the carnival water
gun
the way that it starts there's an irony
to it because he's sitting in a carnival
but the camera comes zooming in close
and he's holding his finger like a gun
like he's gonna do some kind of
action with it and then he points it at
this
party game that starts filling up the
balloon and it pops i love the way that
the
actual prize that he wins just falls
from the sky and he's holding it kind of
real proud of it and decides to show off
a little bit more
by creating a water spout coming from
his hand and that's kind of elevating
the
prize that he just won and it just kind
of stays there with him and the sense of
pride that he won this ridiculous
stuffed animal
[Music]
robocop's friendship is robocop does the
robot
it's a very retro dance sequence
which looks so ridiculous again it's
another example of how
grateful we are that the owners of these
licenses allowed us to do robocop doing
these 80s
90s 2000s dance nods the moonwalk and
all the things
is such a funny thing to see and
everybody will kind of make the
connection robocop doing the robot
again i'm so glad that they allowed us
to do something as silly as that
the music and the performance again this
is another one of those friendships
where
the performance just carries it the
motion capture that talent that we have
and the animators just
nailed the kind of spirit of what this
friendship move is trying to do
scorpion scorpion's friendship i guess
you can call the get over here giant
teddy bear
it was one of the first friendships that
we did where we kind of like set the
tone
of the remaining friendships in the game
he looks like he's going through one of
his
victory moves where he throws his spear
out the camera's this dramatic angle but
instead of some victim being pulled in
it's this big teddy bear and scorpion
just starts hugging him
one of the the details that are in that
particular friendship that i
hope people pick up on is as he's
hugging the teddy bear he looks up and
he
acknowledges the teddy bear one more
time and then continues to hug him and
it's really uh
so opposite of scorpion moment
that kind of defines what the spirit of
these friendship moves is intended to be
[Music]
shang tsung's friendship is like some of
the others
a tribute to his mortal kombat 2
friendship
he basically just kind of creates this
rainbow and it's kind of like this
universal symbol for love and everybody
getting along
which is great this time he has this
sinister look on his face and he's
creating this big spell
that you think something bad is gonna
come out of but then all of a sudden he
just reverts back to that pose with his
arms in the air
opening them up revealing the rainbow
and back to friendship
it's a little bit of a trick there where
he starts sinister
but then he kind of reverts back to that
friendship but it's one of our
quick and simple friendship moves in the
game
[Music]
shao khan along with aaron black and
rain
is a carnival-related friendship move
everybody knows shao khan
he's the big hammer what do you do with
a big hammer you test your might in a
sense and of course he's shao khan so he
breaks the bell at the top
everything shatters and he's all proud
of himself that's his kind of
i break the rules type of thing and
that's again the kind of trifecta of
carnival games that we have in mortal
kombat 11.
[Applause]
[Music]
shiva's friendship is she plays the wine
glasses
[Music]
this is easily the quietest smoothest
most mellow friendship that we have in
the game
with these characters that have four
arms we really try to think of something
novel for them to do
and shiva at the end of the day she
probably would prefer
peace and so we just put a whole bunch
of wine glasses in front of her and
she's just using all four
arms to play the soothing music very zen
but also one of the more simple
friendship moves in the game there's
nothing really complex about it just a
whole bunch of wine glasses that she
plays this little symphony on
[Music]
sindel's friendship is another quick and
simple one it's a bit of a gag
she takes out a wine glass and cindell
is known for
her voice her scream her ability to do
damage with this
voice and so you think that she's going
to scream and
shatter the wine glass but as she is
screaming the camera lens actually
cracks
she gives this sinister laugh
and she just takes a sip of the wine
because why not
i love the kind of little bit of a gag
that's in it where you think she's gonna
do the obvious and then
something else happens i think it might
be our only friendship move that kind of
breaks that fourth wall with the player
it's one of the kind of gag friendship
moves in our games there is no
like physical object that is the lens
throughout the game we use
different fields of view depending on
how dramatic we want to be with
something the mood that we're trying to
set but
that friendship is kind of playing on
that where it's kind of like hey don't
forget you're looking at this video game
through a lens
again that's that little nuance of kind
of breaking that fourth wall
[Music]
scarlett's friendship can be called the
masterpiece
starts out a little dark she's painting
with blood she goes from precision
where she's really concentrating and
then she goes to like these crazy
moments where she's throwing blood at
the canvas you're wondering what is this
gonna be
basically when she reveals it it's a
self-portrait it looks like a child
painted it makes no sense at all the
detail that i love about this one is the
facial expression that she has when it's
done
it's such a childish painting but as any
artist would be
she's just as proud as as can be with
this very basic self-portrait
[Music]
sonia blade's friendship is probably one
of the cuter friendships
in the game she actually plays
fetch with her robot in typical mortal
kombat fashion
that cute little drone which looks like
an 80s movie
robot comes back and it's dragging this
dead body
the irony being that sonia when she sees
it she goes
as if it's something that's really cute
the star of it is her
little robot and it's game of fetch
spawns spawn's friendship is probably
the shortest short and sweet and it
definitely demonstrates the opposite of
a character's
personality spawn who is just the
epitome of
hell and violence it's a special kind of
hell isn't it
this crazy cape suddenly showing him
using the cape
as a hammock and he's reading relaxing
again the music plays such a big
part because it's the saxophone
[Music]
it absolutely sets the mood it's just so
not what you would expect spawn to do
and once again
for the people who created spawn who
allowed us to do this
were very grateful
[Music]
sub-zero's friendship is the ice cream
truck or ice cream vehicle
it opens with the most ridiculous
animation on sub-zero where he's
randomly excited and runs off the screen
and you're kind of wondering what
what are you so excited about he comes
back on the screen with this
old-school ice cream vehicle there's an
umbrella overhead
written on the cooler is sub-zero frozen
treats you see goro with four
cones one in each hand and scorpion
where he dropped his cone because of
course
sub-zero and scorpion are still rivals
at the end of the day so he's not gonna
have a picture of scorpion having fun
at the very end he generates one of his
the popsicles with
with his freeze power of course it's so
childish it's so ridiculous
that's why it works
[Music]
the terminator's friendship is
motorcycle tricks
terminator has one of his kind of like
signature things
is his big motorcycle that he rides on
we thought it would be funny to have him
do
stunts so he leaves and then all of a
sudden he's riding on the motorcycle and
you're like oh okay he's gonna just
exit the scene but then he stands up on
the motorcycle and he's balancing and
that smile that he gives to the camera
that moment is probably the most
entertaining part of that
friendship moves and then he just begins
a process of back and forth
riding with handstand and then you see
him popping a wheelie there's a charm to
it
the fact that everybody knows that face
and everybody knows how serious
terminator traditionally is seeing
terminator with a smile goofing around
in a friendship again we're so grateful
we're allowed to do that
just sells that friendship move
perfectly
so that is every friendship move in
mortal kombat 11. there was a lot to
cover
i hope you learned a little bit about
how we designed these moves and maybe
thought of a different way to finish him